a new partnership with freelancer the
introduction of the watson aiops
customer advisory council
and ibm's top rated awards from trust
radius all
on this episode of ibm cloud now what's
up y'all my name is ian and i am back
to bring you the latest and greatest
news and announcements from ibm cloud
we've got some great topics to cover
this week and i want to start with a new
partnership between the ibm center for
cloud training
and freelancer the world's largest
freelancing and crowdsourcing
marketplace
together they will be making ibm cloud
training programs
available for use in freelancer projects
and contests
this will provide freelancers community
of 51 million participants with the
opportunity to learn cloud skills
an important focus of this program is
that it can help close the skill and
talent gaps that are hindering cloud
adoption
enabling businesses to reap the rewards
of cloud integration by developing a
strong pool
of certified developers freelancers can
even participate in ibm sponsored
contests
and bid on cloud projects allowing them
to build cloud skills
and earn industry recognized
certifications proving their knowledge
to clients in the community
to learn more about this important
program check out the blog link i've
included in the description of this
video
next up we're excited to introduce the
watson ai ops customer advisory council
which provides a platform for us to
partner with our customers
on their journey to maximize ai and
automation efficiencies
the advisory council brings it industry
and ibm leadership together
to engage in dialogue around the
changing itops market landscape
this program formalizes our commitment
to listen and co-create with our
customers in driving the next steps in
it operations
which is artificial intelligence for it
ops or
aiops events will be held once per
quarter
and topics will include
application-centric resource management
reducing mean time to resolution
and other practices used to accelerate
an organization's journey to i.t
operational excellence for more info on
the advisory council and its vision
hit the link below i'm gonna wrap things
up this week with a little bit of a
celebration
because we're proud to announce we've
earned top rated awards from trust
radius
for the second year in a row trust
radius only awards top rated badges to
the products in the top tier of their
categories
and it's fueled by peer reviews the ibm
products that earned this distinction
this year are
the ibm cloud kubernetes service cloud
databases
cloud object storage cloud bare metal
servers cloud virtual servers
ibm watson studio and ibm blockchain
platform
a big thank you to all of our customers
who submitted reviews
because it guides our product roadmaps
and shapes our customer experiences
for a complete rundown on ibm's top
rated awards see the link below
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of ibm cloud now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics i've covered
make sure you explore the links in the
description of this video and again
please don't forget to subscribe to our
channel to stay up to date on what's
going on in the cloud
now